écoutez ici en tout cas au niveau du
métro invalides la situation et festive
dans la situation est revenue au calme
mais pour tout vous dire tout à l'heure
j'étais en train de parler avec notre
invité qui à côté de moi il chamakh et
un gilet jaune
en fait on se disait que c'était un
calme qui al'air précaire c'est à dire
qu'on a vu il ya à peine dix minutes une
charge des forces de l'ordre des
tensions entre les forces de l'ordre et
les manifestants on est totalement nas
est ici c'est impossible de sortir de ce
pré carré effectivement je vous dis on
sent que les choses pourraient dégénérer
assez rapidement comme on le disait tout
à l'heure et cham ne vous vous êtes
gilet jaune depuis le début du mouvement
vous étiez là vous êtes là aujourd'hui
parce que c'était important pour vous de
montrer votre soutien au personnel
soignant
bien sûr donc comme vous l'avez dit au
départ jugé les jaunes depuis le début
du mouvement
aujourd'hui je tenais à la fois marquer
ma sympathie avec le mouvement
hospitalier parce que on voit bien que
le discours de notre président il ya eu
beaucoup de mensonges ou la pas pu dire
honnêtement à nous le peuple français
qui l'a mal gérée
ils ont eu l'intelligence et de 10
rebonds effectivement j'ai peut-être
pris ça à la légère
j'suis désolé on va voir comment on va
améliorer les choses
non pour vous en fait finalement
aujourd'hui c'est la continuité d'un
combat c'est un bras de fer qui se
poursuit en fait effectivement mais ce
que je veux dire on utilise j'aime pas
trop ce terme là parce que conti de
combat donc il ya forcément un rapport
de forces est depuis le début nous les
gilet jaune on est pacifiste
on est là pour
revendiquer nos acquis et les défendre
mais tout en restant pacifiste n'y a pas
de combat les combats il est en face
parce qu'on veut nous faire taire on
veut faire taire cette nouvelle
génération de contestataires on veut
faire taire la population qui donne
demande à ce que c'est nos élus nous
rendent des comptes
on n'est pas dans la toute puissance le
gouvernement ne peut pas s'inscrire donc
dans la toute puissance on nous doit des
comptes et ses comptes
il faut nous les rendre justement de
parler de combat vous parlez de force
on a quand même vu clairement un rapport
de force aujourd'hui pendant cette
manifestation avec les forces de l'ordre
et des groupes de manifestants qui ont
régulièrement
d'ailleurs c'est les manifestions que
commencer pas forcément les soignants
mais des jeunes qu'on a vu cadres et
habillés en noir qui ont commencé à
lancer des projectiles sur des forces de
l'ordre qui étaient plutôt stoïque au
début et qui ont commencé à riposter au
bout d'un moment quand même moi je vais
juste vous donner une phrase
quand ya pas de justice ça pousse à
l'insurrection donc ces jeunes il
demande de la justice il demande qu'une
justice sociale de justice fiscale c'est
ça qu'on réclame et est aujourd'hui moi
je suis heureux je suis heureux parce
que je n'ai jamais vu autant de jeunes
ah ça fait deux ans que tu dors j'ai
jamais vu autant de jeunes sortir depuis
ces trois dernières semaines
et d'ailleurs je tenais à tous les
féliciter vous êtes sorti les gars
maintenant il va falloir vous inscrire
va falloir apprendre pour ne pas tomber
dans le rapport de force dans lequel on
veut nous inscrire on est pacifiste et
on aime notre pays on aime nos
concitoyens on aime nos voisins le hors
de question de sortir pour taper sur son
voisin
voilà bien merci d'avoir à nos questions
j'aime vous entendez ça monte à des
manifestants qui restent déterminés même
s'ils ont l'impression de cette journée
mobilisation a été un peu on va dire
détériorés par les violences qui a eu et
qu'on a relaté tout au long de
l'après-midi mais en tout cas maintenant
à l'heure où je vous parle devant le
métro au niveau du métro des invalides
la situation est très calme festive
ensoleillé il ya des manifestions qui
sont encore là en très grand nombre
quand même et des forces de l'ordre qui
nast totalement c'est ombre en tout cas
où je me trouve mais pas de tension
notable en tout cas à vous signaler à
cette heure-ci où je vous parle
merci la fin boom